has been rather quiet in the last few
weeks what are you hearing what's the
latest on the battlefield it is after
Ukraine's massive successes and pushing
Russia out of the northeastern part of
Ukraine recapturing its territory again
we're in a bit of an operational pause
you know I think we've got a map coming
up in a second which will show that the
Russians are still advancing a little
bit in the center towards the the town
of bakmut but they're on the outskirts
of it they're not in it and to the north
of that north east of isium the
ukrainians are still making
um some advances but I think we're
building up to something happening done
in Harrison and the Russians are pushed
up against the danipro river there's
about 5 000 of them in an area there the
bridges have been taken down their
pontoon bridges and the ferries that are
there haven't got the capacity for them
all to withdraw and certainly when
things go quiet in terms of what the
Ukrainian officials and politicians are
talking about we can expect that
something can expect something to happen
yes but in terms of Russian mobilization
let's talk about that now how many
Russian reservists as far as we
understand have been caught up so far
and indeed how well has it gone
certainly the fact that Putin has
announced domestic mobilization is going
to end suggest it's not gone very well
it is Putin said he wanted to mobilize
300 000 reservists he himself admitted
222 000 so he's he's in the right sort
of ballpark that um uh the West has
assessed but the mobilization the
individuals are coming in there's enough
flood report saying they're not being
trained they're not getting the proper
equipment they're having to buy their
own body armor for example um and then
we saw what happened that the shooting
range at belugrad
um and everything and there are reports
of individuals or groups of um
reservists that have gone into the front
line and have only lasted three or four
days because they don't have the
training certainly the quality of
soldier that is being deployed there now
really does raise huge concern uh does
it doesn't it and in terms of the
Russian strategy at the moment uh is
Vladimir Putin now looking for an escape
room what's happening I I think it's
it's early days to say but we're
beginning to hear the Rumblings of them
doing just that you know he's been
talking about trying to come up with
some form of settlement agreement he's
you're asking for um talks and saying
he'll he'll look at peace talks and bits
and pieces he's focusing on his domestic
audience that's probably what the
mobilization statement was about and
remember he wants to make sure that
there isn't any more dissent in his
domestic audience it was the Russian
mothers that put a lot of pressure on
the Russian government to withdraw from
Afghanistan because the bodies that are
coming back there's an awful lot more
coming out of Ukraine than came out of
Afghanistan and Putin is beginning to
feel the pressure at home interesting
and let's talk about the outside support
uh that Ukraine is getting there's
barely a daily goes by at the moment
that we can't bring up the name Elon
Musk tell us the latest yes Elon is is
the Starling satellite system on offer
back on again
um you know he he's he provided the
starlink satellite system to the Ukraine
to use in the disputed areas give them
Communications that they can't get
through the mobile phone network as as
you know it's it doesn't work um and
other satellite systems that can be
intercepted and then there was a comment
from a Ukrainian official that
criticized Elon Musk personally and he
decided that he would not provide it
anymore and I think he's been persuaded
to provide it now for free he did
emphasize that it's costing his company
about 20 million dollars a month just to
do this and other companies providing
defense capability are actually getting
paid